foreign
[Music]
welcome to the session and good morning
so I'm Richland I'm a product manager at
Google and I spend a lot of time on uh
declarative infrastructure and a big
focus of mine is to help you you know
have the best user experience with
terraform on gcp
so you have to enjoy the journey not the
destination
so I think the answer that I'd give you
really depends on when you ask me this
question right and so at a previous
company I was at a really large
information company and I started off as
a contractor then it became a
virtualization engineer and eventually a
lead automation engineer and you know I
helped provision get infrastructure
provisioning down from about 30 plus
days to 30 minutes and I know it sounds
awesome but that was without terraform
uh so it was infrastructure the hard way
and but the journey didn't begin there
right because like at the end of The
Journey it was like it was amazing like
it was awesome like everything was great
but the journey when it started was not
so awesome right uh and so when it
started there was a an automation team
that was called The A-Team and these
guys were like pros these guys were
awesome
um and they all decided to leave in a
very very short period of time for
whatever reason and so that was my
opportunity right so I was able to come
in and take on everything and I said how
hard can this be right this is not too
bad right but truth be told uh it was
really really really hard the journey
was not easy in the beginning right
um and So eventually I learned about
this thing called terraform
and so that moment I realized that I
could have probably saved about 80
percent of my time and so I questioned
everything that I've ever done uh the
cool part is that it actually led me to
join hashicorp and then eventually I
became a CE at Google and you know now
I'm a PM at Google uh and so you have to
enjoy the journey in order to actually
reach the destination and if you don't
enjoy it it's going to be extremely
extremely painful and so this session
today is actually about three things
right the first thing is that we want
you to enjoy your journey and so
everything I'm going to share with you
today hopefully makes that Journey just
a little bit better and number two we
want to make sure that you know we start
this feedback loop because like
everything we have today is great but
like we also want to make sure we get
the feedback and we you know hear from
you and we know exactly like you know
how to make this better right help us
help you uh lastly we want to make sure
that no matter who you are whether
you're a learner a builder or an
operator you want to make sure that you
can you know onboard onto gcp with
terraform in a very easy way
you know a little bit about me Emerson
said and I want to introduce uh you know
always and poke it who can introduce
themselves real quick
we'll get Chandra I am the director of
product for uh terraform and I focus
primarily on all the Integrations that
surround terraform
uh my name is always Malik and I am a
solution architect with Google Cloud
um my specialty is infrastructure
Automation and later today I'm going to
be talking about a demo that we've built
to help customers kind of move their
solutions to terraform cloud and and
work with them in there
all right thank you
okay all right so today's fairly simple
we're going to talk about how you're
going to adopt build and scale terraform
one gcp uh plugin will give you some
updates from hashicorp and then we'll do
a demo and then we'll hopefully have
some q a
all right before we get started just I
need a quick raise of hand so I just
wanted to kind of know who everybody is
so who in here is just getting started
with terraform he's just like raise your
hand
and if you keep your hands up and if
you're enjoying the Journey Keep Your
Hands Up if you're not put your hands
down
a few of you put your hands down all
right uh and how many of you are like
the terraform ogs like you got like five
years of experience there we go
nice keep your hands up now if you're
enjoying the journey keep them up if
you're not oh if you went down okay
interesting uh how many of you are
Developers
that are also doing terraform
and are you enjoying the journey
oh yes I kind of expected that
developers don't really want to do
everything about terraform right they
want to they want to write their code
and so I get that and lastly like how
many of you are in like a cloud platform
or an SRE team
okay bunch of you all right are you
enjoying the Journey Keep Your Hands Up
a few of you okay put it down all right
so all of you that dropped your hands
meet us outside I'd love to get your
feedback and hear all about exactly why
that journey man is not going so well
right we're here to help you out
so uh before we get any further I want
to level set what's terraform I think
most of us know what terraform is right
you have a user describe the config file
they're going to use terraform with some
providers and then those providers are
going to give you access to certain
resources in this case like we have the
Google cloud provider that's going to
give you access certain resources on
Google Cloud but you may have other
providers as well right so the process
is pretty much the same uh but the the
the benefit to our customers right is
really about number one is that single
workflow I mean I think nobody can deny
like you have one workflow to do it all
right the other thing is that it's a
infrastructure as code so it's code and
you get to do all the things with code
right like Version Control and rollbacks
and collaboration and all that good
stuff and lastly right it's much easier
to adopt new infrastructure in the
future once you're already using
terraform so I think that's that's
really awesome right so what we want to
do now is actually focus a little bit
more on the Google cloud provider and
specifically like resource coverage
and so most of the resource coverage
that you're going to need is already
covered right it's in the provider but
the question is like how do the
resources actually get added into the
provider so someone has to spend some
time adding that in and so traditionally
we have the terraform team like for a
very long time for years they've been
adding these resources they prioritize
they stack Rank and like you know they
make sure they add all the resources
they can but you know it's a handful of
people right and it's not very easy and
so what is Google doing differently in
order to scale coverage what we're doing
is we're working with product and
Engineering teams and service teams to
basically help you know scale this out a
little bit so we're onboarding teams
we're making sure that they can like you
know add these resources faster and so
like the ultimate goal for us is to have
day Zero support and you may get that in
some cases you're not going to get it
for everything right but that's our like
that's our Dream right we want day Zero
coverage for everything you got a
service that comes out on gcp it's
available on terraform
um and lastly hashicorp right I mean the
partnership with Hachi Corp is is
definitely like it's pivotal for Hashi
and Google but I think more importantly
for our customers like we want to give
you the best experience so we work on a
weekly basis we work all the time we
triage you know uh issues and we make
sure we resolve issues in a timely
manner
now I've spoken to hundreds of customers
over the last few years and I gotta say
like yes the provider is the most
important thing without the provider you
have nothing but the fact is that
there's way more that you care about
than just a provider and so today we're
going to talk a little bit about some of
these things right and so like we've
heard you we know that you know you want
more and so hopefully what we discussed
today is going to help you enjoy your
journey just a little bit more
now the first thing is right we have uh
we're proud to announce that we actually
have terraform support on Google cloud
and now you know this is in partnership
with hashicorp and you know it's for
premium support customers actually right
and so what does this mean it means that
the support team is going to triage
these issues they're going to you know
either resolve them if they can if they
can't then they're going to forward it
to the right team right whether it's a
service team or the terraform team or if
it's terraform core issues they're going
to send it to Hashi Corp right
um and so hopefully this is going to
make your experience a lot better
um and if you have Hashi Corp support
and Google Cloud support then that makes
it even better and you'll have even a
better experience there
um and so what does this cover it covers
the gcp terraform provider issues the
API issues uh and also like I mentioned
the terraform core issues but what this
doesn't cover is actually the uh
configuration so like if you have
Blueprints and stuff like that it won't
actually cover that but what you should
do is reach out to your account teams
your CES Etc right like there's like a
whole bunch of them we partnered with
hashicorp and have certified on
terraform everyone's learning more and
more about terraform and we've got those
folks who aren't certified and they're
like terraform gurus right so talk to
your account teams and get help there as
well and if all else fails please reach
out to me and reach out to my team
oh
all right so I'm actually also excited
to partner with the Google Cloud
community in 2023 we're doing a lot more
with terraform right we want to make
sure that you know we provide you live
training and enablement sessions and so
you know stay tuned for that if you sign
up you'll get those updates so the
Google Cloud Community is actually you
know it's going to allow you to get
access to experts you know thousands and
thousands of them your peers and
googlers and some of who are actually
building and and creating your products
right so if you want to take advantage
of this right it's free to sign up uh
you know you can ask questions you can
participate uh maybe you know get some
free prizes with some learning
challenges Etc but I definitely
recommend this it's going to keep you up
to date
all right so this is uh we just recently
launched our first version of the
maturity model the terraform on gcp
maturity model now this is our attempt
to help you better understand where you
are if you're a learner a builder or an
operator like how can you adopt
terraform on gcp uh you scan this
barcode to get all the details right
we're not going to go through everything
today uh but this is definitely going to
cover a lot of things and we partnered
with hashing Corp on this and through
customer feedback
and if you didn't get the QR code don't
worry we'll make sure we get it after
all right first step right uh is the
first phase is adopt and so you might be
a developer you might be new to gcp you
know new to terraform Etc and so like
here's some great resources to get
started one of the first ones is our
terraform docs page um our goal is to
work you know with the content team and
to make sure that we get all terraform
stuff into one place and so this is our
Dream right like we want to make sure
everything's there but like we
definitely need your feedback right
we'll iterate on this we'll improve
um and so make it better and better over
time
now once you have the provider and you
have the resources I think the next most
important thing is the blueprints right
but blueprints is an overloaded term you
may or may not already know this right
but I want to just make sure I clarify
this if I say blueprints for modules in
this talk uh the rest of the time right
like they're pretty much interchangeable
but I do want to describe the
differences a little bit right and so
blueprints are actually the golden
standard of you know of modules in our
opinion right and so they're going to
give you all those things they're going
to give you the resource diagram they're
going to give you tests they're going to
give you all the good stuff
um and so the way I summarize it is that
you know all blueprints include modules
not all modules are blueprints
hopefully that makes sense
so at a high level I want to cover three
things right so if you're just learning
to use resources I'd recommend the one
on the left and that's samples right so
they're very quick to get started and
you're just learning and like they're
pretty pretty fast some of them are a
little lengthy but mostly they're very
quick examples and if you're looking for
opinionated Solutions on gcp then I'd
recommend the center one which is cloud
Foundation toolkit and if you're looking
if like if you're comfortable building
modules yourself and you have experience
with it I'd recommend the cloud
Foundation fabric on the right hand side
and that's a whole session by itself so
we're not going to go too deep in that
uh this is jumpstart Solutions the waste
is going to go into this a little more
detail
um you know this is basically pre-built
applications and infrastructure best
practices right you can deploy with a
few clicks onto your Google Cloud
account and this is going to give you
hands-on experience it's going to give
you interactive environment and so why
would you actually do this right the
reason is like you want to accelerate
your path towards building your own apps
you also want to make sure that you can
quickly build confidence and get
familiar with the Google Cloud you know
products and plus we're going to give
you reference architecture guides
walkthroughs Etc and all of that so it's
going to help you get started really
quickly
uh another thing we want to announce is
that we have uh this thing called
infrastructure manager and
infrastructure manager like a waste is
going to talk about it more but what I
want to share with you is that Google is
actually leveraging info manager on our
Solutions so in the previous example
jumpstart you can deploy with a few
clicks and that capability is provided
through infrastructure manager the other
thing is that info manager actually went
GA recently and so you can actually play
around with it you know you can scan the
QR code you can take a look and see if
that's interesting to you
um and so again like I mentioned there's
a lot more things on the on the on the
guide right I think one of the main
things I'd mentioned is like the the
cloud skill boost like we had some
really good trainings here if you're
interested in the training with like
four and a half five stars thousands of
reviews uh lots of terraform sessions
there's also a terraform certification
prep uh it's actually really really good
very well received
now as a builder right you already have
experience with infrastructure you may
already have experience with gcp right
and so you may be a developer you may be
an SRE you may be a platform admin or a
cloud team right
um and now so when you're learning right
you may not have all the foundations in
place uh you know and it takes some time
so if you're not familiar we have the
Google Cloud security Foundation right
it's going to basically give you an
opinionated view of Google Cloud's best
practices and now you know what is cloud
setup so Cloud setup is a multi-step
guide that's going to give you the
ability to walk through and lay out your
foundations and at the end you have the
choice you can either click and deploy
which again uses info manager or you can
download the terraform configurations
and you'll be able to deploy it in your
own Pipelines
and this is also another cool feature
in the console and you've you know
filled out a VM form and then you said
give me the equivalent rest or give me
the equivalent you know CLI now you can
also get the equivalent terraform
commands this won't work for every
product but our product teams are
working to integrate this and make it
better and I'd recommend like reaching
out to the product teams and letting
them know that you want to see this
faster
all right again like before there's
definitely lots of other you know
material there for you to look at and
mainly it's like if you want to
customize blueprints customize jumpstart
Solutions right you want to create your
own blueprints you want to create your
own modules you want some more advanced
you know uh Cloud skill boost and all of
that right you'll get access to all of
that
and now how do you scale so as an
operator right
um you already have experience with
Google Cloud you have experience with
terraform right a lot more than others
right but you may be on a platform team
maybe on a cloud team an SRE team Etc
but how do you scale terraform on gcp we
can talk about this for hours so I'm not
going to do that to you today it's going
to cover a few things
the the main thing here I think is the
our best practices we spend a lot of
time on this it's a comprehensive best
practice guide you could start when
you're adopting you could start when
you're building of course but like if
you're if your goal is to scale uh you
definitely want to you know look through
this and and more importantly right
there's a lot of variables it's not very
straightforward there's a lot of pieces
and a lot of teams that I've talked to
they typically just get started and they
figure out the best practices along the
way and then you realize like it's not
so easy to like fix everything again
right and so talk to hashicorp talk to
Google and let us help you like kind of
figure out like what the best practices
are and how you know you can get started
but also when you're scaling right the
decisions you make early on are going to
dictate how you are going to enjoy that
Journey right and so the more best
practices you know you you're familiar
with I think the better experience
you're going to have on gcp
so as an operator you have lots and lots
of decisions to make right like we get
questions all the time like you know how
do you take advantage of the producer
consumer model how do you scale on gcp
what are the best practices you know
policy governance Etc so there's a lot
of different things but one of the most
popular questions I think is build
versus buy and I think everyone here at
some point has gone through some sort of
experience around build versus buy
um when I think of build versus buy I
can think of one particular personal
story and I just want to share that with
you today
so in 2015 my wife and I we purchased
our first home long story short uh we
want to do some renovation we hired a
contractor we started off as like this
little Renault turn into an entire gut
job right like I gutted the entire house
and all the bathrooms which is a whole
other story of why I did that it was
definitely a mistake uh but you know
like my contractor decided a few weeks
in like he's gonna leave me and so I
talked to my wife I was like we got this
like we're going to do this ourselves
and we decided to do it ourselves uh and
so the journey began
now that smile is genuine
but that guy don't know what I know 100
uh and so you know my wife she was you
know my wife she's an interior designer
or for this house she was uh and change
orders weren't a thing for her right
like she just makes changes and I just
have to implement those changes she was
like my first customer as a general
contractor my first and last actually uh
and I did everything I was the floor guy
I was the Mason I was the you know I did
all of it the plumbing the electrical
even the HVAC system
um and I learned a ton right and of
course I hired help that's my daughter
Iman she's helping in his Free Labor
which is great uh but long story short I
moved in in 2017.
now the end results are truly awesome
like of course like I'm so happy like we
spent all this time we spent all this
money but like we have a home and we're
very very happy right uh and I learned a
lot and it's not just about building a
home I learned a lot about myself right
like in that process
um and I also learned what I'm capable
of and I think in Tech right that's kind
of what it's about like when we build
like that's what we're trying to do
we're trying to learn and through that
process no matter how hard it is no
matter how much you Bang Your Head on
the keyboards like at the end of the day
that growth and that learning is all
what it's about right so there's a
definitely value there but then if you
ask me today 100 I enjoyed this journey
now this is where the story gets
interesting
so three months before I moved in my
neighbor
he buys a house
and he gutted the whole thing and not
only that he built an entire second
floor
and he moved in exactly when I moved in
so to put it all into perspective like
yes money is a factor you're right but I
spent a lot of money as well just like
he did but in three months he had a
whole brand new house and he moved in
with me
now what does this have to do with
building infrastructure in my opinion I
think a lot right collectively in here
you probably have Decades of experience
of infrastructure configuration
management uh maybe centuries I'm not
sure right and in some way you know I
think most of you probably know where
I'm going with this already
um and so on one end
I could build you a house today right I
know my house inside and out and like
many of you you know your systems inside
and out
um and so I know what's Behind the Walls
if something breaks I know exactly how
to fix it
um and but if someone were to buy my
house
probably going to struggle a little bit
maybe right they don't know everything
like I know
um and so now if I were able to build
you a house again I can do it better I
can do it more cost effectively I can
make sure it's I can do it faster
because I've learned through that
process and that's I think what Bill
gives you right it's like it's going to
give you that experience over time now
here are the facts it took me two years
to move in
took me two years of mortgages it took
me two years of living with my parents
that was great it's not a bad thing but
like I put them at inconvenience and two
years of my life and no time with my
family that I could never get back and
if you asked me today
would I ever go back and change it I
probably wouldn't because I did learn a
lot and I really appreciated it but I
100 would do things a little differently
so
here are some considerations right Our
intention is not to tell you what
decision to make whether you build or
you buy what Our intention is is to help
customers to make well-informed
decisions right you may have different
needs right maybe you have different
automation needs maybe you have
different support needs right and
security and and compliance needs maybe
you're in terms of resources you don't
have all the in-house talents maybe you
do right and that all depends in terms
of budget but it's real it's a thing
right like you gotta actually consider
it and so all of that factors in
um and so there's a lot of additional
considerations as well like
organizational culture timeline Etc and
all that stuff uh but what we want you
to do is to Choose Your Own Adventure
right like Google is providing you some
solutions and some documents and some
tools and all of that to make your life
a little bit better to make a journey a
little bit better how she's going to
provide you with terraform Tara from
Enterprise terraform cloud and all of
that right and the demo waste is going
to show you is going to show you how you
can actually get started now you don't
have to make the decision right away but
then later on you can migrate to another
solution like terraform Cloud right and
and how we're going to make that easier
for you so
as you embark on this journey to
automate your infrastructure please
remember to enjoy the ride and if you
need help along the way we're here for
you and with that thank you for
listening I'm going to hand it off to
book it
thank you
all right continuing the journeys
um I'm gonna share some of the updates
that hashicorp is trying to invest
continuously in terraform and what are
the some of the latest things that we
are looking at
all right
um first off terraform and Google as
arslan was talking about like the
partnership is really strong we are
building a lot of things together
um and our Focus right now is uh we make
it extremely easy for customers to do uh
deployment of terraform Enterprise on
Google cloud and Google kubernetes
engine in fact so with this flexible
deployment option that we recently
released in beta and will be going GA
pretty soon you can actually run
terraform Enterprise on any kind of
cloud infrastructure and kubernetes is
one of the favorite ones for a lot of
customers and GK is one of the best
places to run kubernetes so that's what
we support
uh
oops I made a mistake sorry
all right uh
the previous one I I forgot to mention
one thing which is like agents so
another thing that we're working on is
uh agents architecture that you can
actually run something in your in
private infrastructure or some different
Cloud when you're using terraform cloud
and the Agents would help you
manage some of the operations locally
that's cool based system uh and uh it's
pretty effective especially for
companies that are more compliance and
security focused
here's the one that I wanted to talk
about which is flexible deployment
option now available uh something that
you can run on gke and uh one of the
biggest challenges that we have seen
with terraform Enterprise is that it's
available on replicated and there has
been some uh opinions that our customer
wanted some some of the different type
of deployment options and now with
flexible deployment option you can
actually deploy it in different
different uh infrastructure and gke
being one of them
the next up is there from cloud operator
for kubernetes now
as as you all are aware that they're
from cloud is a SAS solution and it it's
it runs fine it's available but a lot of
times customers want a more native
kubernetes experience what this operator
brings in is that terraform Cloud
functionality to the kubernetes system
and you can use functionalities like
drift detection checks
and access the large very stable
terraform provider ecosystem inside of
kubernetes using kubernetes native API
so that's a pretty convenient way of
giving this functionality to our users
and we'll continue to invest in this
we'll continue to expand its uh
operations as as we go along that's
currently available in beta it's going
to go ga very soon uh we'll probably
announce more at coupon
um speaking of uh Cloud agents that we
have introduced before we have a lot of
Investments going in that direction and
uh
and those Cloud agents as I said like
this is more a
a system where you can
agents can actually pull information
from the terraform Cloud so I'm much
more of a pull based mechanism much more
secure
and doesn't really require something
that is sitting outside of your network
to reach inside uh and so it's much more
secure and we plan to have
sorry I have some mistakes in the notes
yeah perfect so we have these modules
which are available uh with the
terraform sorry Google Cloud which Oasis
is also going to probably touch on that
we've developed in conjunction with
Google and it basically allows you to
deploy agents on manage infrastructure
and do a container engines
Etc
and with that I'm going to hand it over
to Louise
sure thanks
so for this part of the presentation
we're going to look at a demo of this
thing called jumpstart Solutions and a
proof of concept application that we've
built called super
um that can help customers evolve
solution management as they step through
the maturity model that our salons has
talked about a few minutes ago
um so let's take that maturity model and
overlay that on top of a typical journey
of a customer that's adopting gcp as
their cloud provider
the first thing they'll typically do is
explore what gcp has to offer in terms
of product and services right next
they'll try to learn how to set up those
typical use cases for example a web
application or a data warehouse
on using those services and products
once they get comfortable with the the
setup and initial you know use cases
they'll want to evolve those Solutions
and make them their own something a
little more production grade something
with customer requirements more secure
before they open that up to the masses
right
and while they're doing that
um change management and governance is
going to become a priority
um more specifically how do you make
sure that you're you're promoting
changes to your code base of your
application as well as the underlying
infrastructure in a controlled manner so
to help with this journey we've done a
couple of things number one we've got
this
feature called jss jumpstart solutions
that helps with the earlier part of the
journey which is exploring learning and
then we have this concept called Hooper
right now it's not part of the console
yet but we'd like your feedback if
that's something like you'd like to see
there we're just going to help with the
latter part of the journey which is
building and operating
so
with that we're going to go ahead and
and look at this demo here let me
try to get this set up
so to start off you know let's just
assume that this is a customer that is
beginning their Journey with Google
Cloud
and um you know the the good place to be
there is
um jumpstart Solutions it's going to
give you a list of opinionated Solutions
authored by Google Cloud
um that you can leverage quickly for
this demo we're going to take a look at
this three-tier web application and
clicking on that card is going to bring
up the solutions detail page which tells
me everything I need to know about the
solution right I have the description
here
I can tell the products being used
within the solution and also how they
kind of connect with each other in a
logical manner there's Cloud run there's
Cloud SQL memory store and VPC
serverless access for cloud run the
diagram kind of depicts what's going on
there right additionally I've got some
more information like
um the the the price and the deployment
time and so on and so forth there's a
couple ways you can deploy this you can
deploy directly through the console or
you can actually go through GitHub if
that's what you prefer to do download
the code base directly available there
and use the terraform CLI to do that
directly but since you know we're
learning and exploring we'll we'll go
ahead and do that directly here
um select a project configure view
details like region and Zone
review the settings and then hit deploy
so with that you have the solution
deployed within gcp this basically uses
this new service that we just went GA
with recently called infrastructure
manager which is essentially a managed
terraform deployment experience you give
it a configuration
it gives you the resources based on
those configurations and it manages the
state for you so it has a terraform
Runner and everything and it basically
gives you what you ask for while
managing the state for you so in a
minute here we'll see that this solution
is deployed
and there you have it so this solution
essentially at this point has
joined some of the other solutions that
we've deployed in this project so
let's just take a pause and see what we
did we we were exploring
we learned about certain Solutions
we picked three-tier web app and we went
ahead and deployed it right so let's
assume as a customer I want to take that
the retier web app and I want to extend
it right what do I need for that
um number one I'm at the very least
going to need a forked instance of the
code base right uh that I can extend
because right now this code base is
probably given it's it's read only I
need to take that and I need to start
extending it and then secondly I need a
workspace space where I can collaborate
with my team members that have the
terraform runner in it so if I make
changes to my code base
those changes can actually travel up to
the gcp resources as they reconcile so
to address that challenge
we're going to see how super our proof
of concept is going to address that
so we're going to bring up super here so
like I said it's not in the console yet
but it works off the public apis and
right now it's connected to the same
project where we had the solutions
deployed
so we select that project and we have
all the listing here
now our goal is to move the tiered web
app solution right at the top
into terraform cloud
right because that's where we're going
to start making changes to it
um
but I'm going to here pause for a second
here just to kind of explain a few more
things
um
so we we need a space for the git
repository that we can extend
so for that we need to configure host
such as GitHub where we can put that
code right and the second place is the
workspace where we can actually
collaborate with our team members and
review changes as they come in so for
that we're going to select here from
cloud right so these are the two hosts
that we're going to go ahead and
configure within this application here
so there's terraform Cloud being
configured in a bit
so we can bring it up we'll give it an
ID and a name and since this is
terraform Cloud the host will be
app.terraform.io
if you choose to do this in a privately
hosted terraform Enterprise version
that's also possible
the US token would have access to create
workspaces and there you have that
registered we're doing we're going to do
the same thing for the git host as well
for the Repository
and we'll do that there
ID name and since
um this is a demo I'm just going to use
my personal
GitHub host account here to create the
repository and the as token would have
access to create repositories in my
organization so we have the pre-rex
setup now
and let's go back to deployments and
we'll try to migrate this
um
so we're going to bring up the migration
panel
and we selected the host terraform Cloud
which has access to this gcp migration
organization in terraform cloud
right and that's the workspace that
we're going to create in there
similarly the GitHub host that we
selected here has access to create
repositories and that's what the
repository name is going to be and with
that we're just going to go ahead and
hit migrate
and now the migration has started right
so there's a few things happening here
number one we're setting up a terraform
workspace
number two we're cloning the code from
the existing jss code base to the git
repository where we just created the the
Repository
number three we're taking the state out
of infra manager where it was being
managed within gcp we're taking that
state and putting it in terraform
workspace now
so there's no changes when it reconciles
and then lastly the new repository that
we just created we're connecting it to
the workspace so we can start to track
changes there right and now
um we can tell that it's it's been
migrated
and at this point
the solution that we wanted to make our
own we have it available in in terraform
workspace where we can start making
changes to it and start reconciling it
so we'll take a look at that
in a little bit
migration so yeah that's the last
migration that we just did
and we'll go ahead and see how things
are looking in terraform Cloud world
right so that's the workspace that we
just did and we can see that it is
currently planning so it's just trying
to figure out is there any changes here
that I need to reconcile but because we
brought the state over
there's not going to be any changes here
to do
um it turned green so the details would
confirm that as well zero changes to the
resources
and now let's start extending this right
so
um the GitHub link right on the top
there
is going to take us to the git
repository where we actually cloned and
and
forked that repository that we took from
DSS right so that's our repository there
and we'll change it to the branch that
the workspace is tracking for changes
and uh we'll just go ahead and make a
very insignificant change like
maybe add a label to one of the
resources
just to demonstrate that it's working
and we'll go ahead and do this directly
in GitHub it's a pretty pretty nice
interface here
scroll down
and there we have it right so we'll just
go ahead and add a label call manage by
terraform cloud
and we'll go ahead and commit this
change directly to the branch
now in in a real world scenario
obviously you're not going to do this
you're probably going to have a better
get Ops process than that but
for the purpose demonstration we're just
going to do it there
foreign
and just to make sure that that's the
only change that we did we'll look at
the history for that commit
that's the only change right now
theoretically this should
be propagated up to the workspace or we
can review it and we can see that now it
has started planning
so shortly it should show that there's a
change that needs to be reconciled
and there it is right so there is one
change and if we look at the details
we should see that
that was the resource that we changed
and that was the change that we made to
the resource and if this looks good to
me as a code reviewer and an approver
I can go ahead and put my comments apply
it and this change would actually
propagate all the way to the resource
labyrinth in this case
so
just recapping what we did here we
started off our journey with just
exploring and learning about products we
picked up a use case we deployed it very
quickly using the info manager all
within gcp
now we wanted to extend it we took out
the solution from infer manager put it
into terraform cloud
and now we can start making more changes
and kind of scale that that process a
lot more okay thank you thank you
everybody
[Applause]